[Music]
I'm dealing with the future of the
planet under necessary shock to the
system I am human evolutionary change
bulletproof superhuman you bad guy the
mission has been compromised
we need help our targets name is Brixton
he's a ghost we're gonna need the best
trackers in the business lucasz on what
you call a nice cold can of whoop-ass
career lawmen always gets his guy
we're gonna need to operate outside the
system Deckard Shaw I'm what you might
call a champagne Robo rogue former mi6
agent doesn't play well with others
if we stand a chance against bricks
today you guys have to work together no
this job requires stealth look at you
I'm trying to save the world which for
the record will be my fourth time
cuz I'm really good at it you haven't no
idea what we're dealing with
Hobbs is sure
you've got one
remember me
oh sure 1 2 3
[Music]
three shocks will kill a man there we go
the bad guy spit a big mouth huh yeah I
thought it was cool thing say in the
moment
[Music]
[Applause]